[Musica]
ero un bambino molto irrequieto e i miei
genitori erano disperati perché non
dormivo e allora hanno deciso di farmi
fare sport
già da quando avevo due anni a due anni
nuoto a tre anni sci poi un po di altre
attività
ma nulla mi è piaciuto tanto come quando
ho iniziato a fare scherma nel 1189 o
sei anni perché mi poteva mi dava la
possibilità di portare quello che era il
mio gioco preferito fare il moschettiere
renderlo per mare al lavoro nel senso
già quando avevo 6 anni perché il lavoro
di bambini a giocare quindi per me era
fenomenale i miei genitori mi avevano
insegnato è che io nella vita potevo
essere tutto ciò che volevo a patto che
ci mettesse tutto me stesso
fossi costante e sapessi pagarne il
prezzo
io nel 1189 ho deciso anzi poco dopo in
realtà quando nove anni ho deciso che
avrei vinto le olimpiadi e spoiler alert
ce l'ho fatta nel 2008
sono riuscito a vincere un oro che
mancava all'italia dal
1960 è tuttora sono l'unico invita ad
avere questo questo roma ma come ho
fatto me lo chiedo spesso anche io
la base è stata a credere a credere
fermamente
visualizzare essere convinto ripetersi
in continuazione perché la mente guida
guida le proprie azioni nella direzione
giusta ieri poteva tutti quanti ripeteva
me stesso e agli altri che io avrei
vinto le olimpiadi
naturalmente a 9 anni faceva molto
ridere mia madre era la prima che invece
sia amore mio però lo dicevo e ho
scoperto poi che
c'erano altri sportivi molti famosi che
che hanno fatto questa cosa
un'altra cosa fondamentale è stato
pensare a lungo termine come ho già
detto la questione dei nove anni mi ha
guidato io ho iniziato ho investito in
un qualcosa senza nessun supporto
all'inizio senza che nessuno
mi credesse per ogni mia azione era
legato a quell'obiettivo
quindi la dieta quindi l'allenamento ma
parlo già di quando ero piccolino ed era
tutto partiva tutto da me e poi
veramente perché pensando a lungo
termine sia quel vantaggio di tempo io
facevo quella cosa da molto più tempo
degli altri io ero già un professionista
quando ero un bambino nella mia testa
purtroppo naturalmente mi sono trovato a
dover andare contro cosa vuol dire
andare contro
andare contro banalmente
ai professori che soprattutto ai miei
tempi era una mentalità giurassica mi
prendono quasi in giro per quello che
facevo andare contro agli amici che
vogliono che tu esca con loro la sera
andare contro alla tua ragazza del
momento che non vuole condividere il tuo
cuore la tua mente con un altro pensiero
generale andare un po contro tutto e
avere una mentalità un po differente
perché la gente tende a non capire che
quando non capire quando non capisce
osteggia ciò che è diverso e fa strano
dirlo banche anche noi atleti a volte
sia dei diversi
bisogna quindi prendere delle decisioni
intendo decisioni forti
io ho iniziato 13 anni quando ho scelto
la spada che in italia è la meno comune
perché è molto tecnica è quella che
viene scelta di meno anche se in realtà
è l'arma con con più iscritti in tutto
il mondo e la più difficile quella con
più persone dove meno facile riuscire a
vincere una gara a 19 anni me ne sono
andato via di casa da solo non aveva un
piano b non c'era un piano b non c'era
altro in testa che fare tutto il
possibile per raggiungere
quell'obiettivo
c'è questa questa frase che
di rober forst due strade divergevano in
un bosco e io ho preso quella meno
battuta e da qui tutta la differenza è
venuta perché per essere differenti
bisogna essere egregi ex gregis fuori
dal gregge
bisogna pensare fuori dagli schemi
io ho avuto sempre la fortuna che c'era
pochissima frizione tra il mio pensiero
e la mia azione io pensavo una cosa
iniziamo a farla e poi facevo degli
aggiustamenti dopo che ero partito però
questo mi dava la possibilità di essere
più avanti degli altri che erano ancora
quel bivio a pensare se partire o meno
bisogna di sicuro attraversare la paura
questo è termine tra virgolette che ho
coniato nel senso che di solito si dice
combattere la paura o eliminare la paura
attraversare è perché io vado nella
direzione della paura lo devo fare
perché devo andare contro il mio
avversario però questo e mi ha insegnato
molto la paura fondamentale la paura ti
rende scattante ti rende ti rende pronto
però ti può bloccare
per non farmi bloccare dalla paura come
quando ero in finale olimpiadi questa è
una foto le olimpiadi
in finale contro questo francese
fortissimo doveva vincere lui parte in
svantaggio penso ok potrei anche perdere
va bene un argento olimpico tutto ok
però poi dicono io devo andare contro
devo andare contro di lui tutto quello
che ho fatto mi ha portato qui e io devo
andare contro quella paura come faccio
non lo so non so come faccio e quindi
sono andato sono andato ci ho pensato
dopo resto è storia
ho vinto io ho vinto anche abbastanza
facilmente però quello che voglio
lasciarvi e il fatto che dalla prima la
quattordicesima stoccata di 15 io ho
avuto paura sempre sempre fino alla
penultima stoccata di poter perdere ed è
per questo che ho vinto
naturalmente sono fatti dei fallimenti
fallimenti insegnano ma anche questi
spesso bloccano
perché bisogna saper reagire i
fallimenti bisogna saper andare oltre
anche in questo caso ve ne racconto 1
l'anno dopo le olimpiadi
sono vicino arrivò in finale ai mondiali
sono vicino a un qualcosa che non è
ancora stato raggiunto mai in italia da
nessuno cioè la doppietta consecutiva
olimpiadi mondiali sta vincendo la
finale abbastanza facilmente una delle
gare più belle della mia vita
litigo con con il ct della nazionale
perde la concentrazione perdo la finale
15 14 ma vicino andarci vicino a conta
sulla bocce una scherma
quindi si sono secondo sono secondo i
mondiali sono vicecampione mondiale
comunque un risultato pazzesco ma in
parte un fantasma terribile non riesco a
dormire per mesi e non riesco più a
vincere per più di un anno
arrivo arrivo al punto che non so più
cosa fare e chiedo aiuto inizia a
lavorare con un mental coach
per fortuna
capisco che mi devo perdonare cosa che
non riuscivo a fare e soprattutto devo
perdonare gli altri io continuavo a dare
la colpa al cta al coach dicevo io ho
perso per colpa sua e quindi non
riuscivo a migliorare e invece ho
imparato a concentrarmi su quello che
potevo fare io da quel momento quello
anche se qualcosa veniva sbagliato dagli
altri cosa potevo fare io per essere
migliore cosa poteva fare io per essere
l'artefice del mio destino a capo della
mia vita
per citare qualcun altro
e da lì sono riuscito a riprendere a
vincere sono riuscito a riprendere
per lungo tempo
anche dopo un infortunio
l'ultimo punto che che l'ultimo
pillola che voglio lasciare è una cosa
che ci ho imparato per tutta la mia vita
alla fine tra la mia vita è un
adattamento alla situazione però l'ho
imparata veramente
adesso
recentemente
mi sono trovato
ultimamente ha seguito tra l'altro
proprio di quella degli screzi che sono
nati da quella finale mondiale ad essere
meno considerato ho avuto un po di
problemi con la federazione a seguito di
un infortunio e
è cominciato ad avere meno spazio
purtroppo la scherma non è uno degli
sport principali se non sei
costantemente in copertina se non vinci
si dimenticano di te e quindi gli
sponsor ti abbandonano io sono un atleta
dell'aeronautica militare e senza senza
la nautica non avrei potuto fare quello
che ho fatto perché mi ha dato una borsa
di studio uno stipendio che mi ha
permesso di fare la mia vita ma è sempre
servito anche supporto degli sponsor e
io avendo meno possibilità di vincere
gare ho cominciato a non averne più
nel 2018 avuto un figlio che ha
completamente cambiato la mia vita e il
mio tempo e quindi mi sono trovato a un
certo punto a un altro bivio dove ho
detto cosa faccio smetto faccio quello
che che che tutti si aspettano
mi trovo un modo e mi sono inventato un
modo o destrutturato la vita la mia vita
da atleta e ho deciso di usare le mie
competenze in in altri ambiti ho dovuto
adattarmi veramente ho dovuto iniziare
creando una presenza social che io non
avevo perché ho vinto nel 2008 e dal
momento in cui i social iniziavano e
creando un blog settimanale e un podcast
dove tratto gli argomenti che stanno
avendo un discreto successo
ho dovuto o voluto creare un crowd
funding per per riuscire a finanziare le
mie stagioni perché io ho dovuto partire
dal drider e questo mi ha portato in
realtà riuscire quest'anno a rientrare
in nazionale
e chissà cosa potrò fare l'anno prossimo
ho scritto uno spettacolo teatrale
perché tutti queste skill mi hanno
ispirato e ho deciso di creare uno
spettacolo teatrale che ha già avuto una
pre rappresentazione a tema a duello a
chiama vita
in un certo senso forse c'è anche dietro
il mio duello con la vita e e poi sempre
utilizzando tutte tutte queste cose che
ho imparato sono riuscito a creare una
start up che non c'entra niente con la
scherma però è un è una start up che che
crea eventi eco sostenibili per le
aziende quindi un b to b quindi non
c'entra assolutamente niente con quello
che ho fatto per ho usato le mie skill
ha usato la mia vita per ricreare
rinnovarmi quindi alla fine questo è
quello che vi lascio lì ho lasciato
questo piccolo riassunto in sette punti
però pensare fuori dagli schemi
mi ha portato a 39 anni con un figlio di
a essere ancora quel bambino che giocava
con la spada e mi diverto un sacco
[Applauso]